Citizens of the world
i'm here to change your life
I wanna be an apex predator get used to it
nothing good is born from lies and
greatness is not what you think
i can save today but you can save the world
i've never been one for rules the answer
is always more
what did you do
you know i'm not so keen on this one i
figure you are but
you know what i'm ready to go i think we
can do better parachute pants
yeah um does everybody parachute now
Welcome back everyone it's charlie so
they dropped a new wonder woman 1984
trailer with a bunch of new footage
we'll break it down
also talk about what's going on with
wonder woman in the justice league
snyder cut in the future of the dceu
now that we know that the flash movie or
at least the flash producers have talked
about rebooting the dceu a little bit
with the flashpoint twist
so if you're new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos we'll
do a new amazon giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and let me know what you want
them to do with wonder woman going
forward
in new dc movies if you've been watching
all the other big justice league actors
and the newer dc movie actors like the
shazam people or the rock and the black
adam movie talk about wonder woman
everybody wants her to cross over into
their movies that are coming up
but the new trailer opens with a bunch
of different scenes focusing mostly on
the big final battle between wonder
woman and cheetah on that island or the
remote location where the special
transmission station is for maxwell lord
to broadcast his magical wishing stone
effect around the world simultaneously
that's called the dream stone that black
rock they use to make all those wishes
that's what he's talking about when he's
speaking in the trailer inside the white
house
people of the world i'm here to change
your life the white house scene though
is from earlier in the movie you can
chart the timeline of the movie in the
trailer footage just based on what
cheetah looks like how she starts out as
that awkward comedic barbara minerva
version of the character who's just a
normal archaeologist alongside wonder
woman at the smithsonian
then maxwell lord discovers and gets his
hands on the dream stone which was made
by a god
but it's a bit of a monkey's paw
situation where yes you're getting
wishes granted but something really bad
usually winds up happening to you as a
result of that wish
so they use it to start making their
wishes and she starts getting more and
more powerful
seemingly getting wonder woman's powers
or at least getting powerful like her
because her big desire at least in the
first part of the movie is to be
just like wonder woman because you could
tell from that conversation in the
earlier trailer when they're talking
about steve trevor and being in love she
idolizes her like a goddess
technically wonder woman is a demigod
though but wonder woman and kind of the
message of the movie is like uh no
not exactly it doesn't work like that my
life isn't as perfect as you think
referencing all the people she's lost
along the way mostly in service of
setting up that big steve trevor twist
but of course because cheetah is going
full blown comic book cheetah in the
movie
she totally misses the point all she can
think about is just leveling up her life
wonder woman 1984 is mostly meant to be
a movie about what greed does to people
metaphorically and literally because it
is a comic book movie so the metaphors
become literal by the end of the movie
you become a metaphorical monster but
then you literally turn into a monster
like when she goes full blown comic book
cheetah
but there's a different scene of her
lassoing the lightning bolts which looks
totally badass i can't wait to see how
they explain that in the movie
then she's dodging all the cannon fire
and then there's a totally new scene of
her using the golden armor to literally
fly and take out the guards that are
protecting maxwell lore's big fortified
broadcast station
you get a really good look at how the
golden armor wings actually articulate
like bird wings or angel wings depending
on how you want to look at it
wonder woman is a character built on
greek mythology so you could also make
icarus and daedalus references but it's
magically enchanted armored just like
her gauntlets or the lasso of truth the
armor is ancient in the context
of the movie it's like an heirloom built
by one of her ancestors forged from the
pieces of a bunch of different armor
sets belonging to other
notable amazon warriors from their
history on themyscira
but it was originally designed to be a
war suit worn by regular amazons
wonder woman doesn't need to wear armor
because she's almost as powerful as
superman
almost almost nothing can pierce her
skin
the whole reason why she has to wear it
in the movie is because by this point
late in the game
so much of her natural power has been
drained by the dream stone that she's
just as squishy as a regular human
and cheetah has already leveled up again
for the second time into her final boss
form
full-blown comic book cheetah as we
finally saw and even when wonder woman
is
at full strength cheetah's claws are
powerful enough to pierce her skin
so with her being de-powered cheetah
would rip through her like tissue paper
if she weren't wearing special armor
you could make a lot of batman v
superman references with batman's giant
suit the tank suit that he wore when he
was trying to fight superman
zack snyder made some jokes and
references when he was explaining it
when the movie originally came out he
said that it's not so much about
protecting him from superman or
preventing superman from killing him
it's really just him wearing that suit
of armor to buy him a couple extra
seconds
because superman is so powerful it's
like crushing a soda can so that's why
it was so critical when they were
fighting each other that he was using
the kryptonite otherwise superman would
have just squished him like a bug no
matter what kind of armor he was wearing
but even late in the game here during
wonder woman 1984 when she's wearing the
armor and she's lost most of her powers
it seems like she still has the lasso of
truth and it seems like that hasn't lost
any of its potency to the dream stone
i love all this old school 80s
technology through all these montages
when maxwell lord is speechifying doing
his big villain monologue trying to get
the world to drink his kool-aid
the whole mall fight scene later in the
trailer actually happens a bit earlier
in the movie
it's going down when everybody starts
riding in the streets after this first
big tv broadcast where you see everyone
in the street watching him and they
start making wishes
causing all kinds of havoc the reason
why everyone starts going full blown
crazy town is just a side effect of the
dream stone granting everyone's wishes
simultaneously in what it takes from
them in return
like the law of equal exchange you can't
create something out of nothing
you have to take from one thing to give
to another so one person makes a wish it
inadvertently starts affecting the
people around them in negative ways
and this is also true of the steve
trevor twist too
so her big wish is for steve trevor to
come back and that
inadvertently brings him back to life
but it just doesn't magic him up out of
nothing they actually have to take from
someone else's body
to bring steve trevor back i believe the
movie is supposed to explain that twist
pretty well it'll be pretty easy to
follow the cheetah leopard print 80s
fashion is totally out of control i
can't wait to see kristen wiig go full
comic book in the movie
most of the footage of her at various
points in her transformation process do
a pretty good job of showing her range
as she slowly descends from normal
person to comic book villain
you can really see the twist here when
she takes down the mugger this is really
early on when she just starts to notice
her new abilities like hey wait a minute
i'm super
fast and super strong then there's a
scene of what looks like her
using the lasso of truth to full blown
fly through the air but it's not clear
when this is happening during the movie
wonder woman of the dc eu can actually
fly she even does it at the end of the
first wonder woman movie that's what's
happening when she's launching off of
the roof of the louvre in paris
i think the reason why we haven't seen
her fly in any huge fight scenes or big
battle scenes up to this point
like not flying during the theatrical
cut of justice league is just because
they were saving
that for the wonder woman sequels and
they wanted it to feel like some big
character development moment like
superman flying for the first time in
man of steel is meant to be a really
special character development moment for
him as he's leveling up
but if you guys are watching all the dc
fandom panels and the justice league
snyder cut footage obviously there's a
whole bunch of new wonder woman scenes
during the justice league snyder cut
that'll sort of explain what's going on
with her character in the future of the
dc eu
i've gotten so many questions about
whether or not the snyder cut
is going to replace the theatrical cut
as the new canon of the dceu
i think if you want to you can take it
that way the studio probably won't fight
anybody on that like if you want to
think of this as the new canon then sure
go for it
when it comes down to continuity and
character beats for the most part the dc
filmmakers the different directors
kind of are doing their own things with
the characters in each of their movies
there's just a loose continuity that
sort of ties everything together
when they get to wonder woman 3 when
that movie eventually comes out patty
jenkins will again just kind of do what
she wants to with the character loosely
acknowledging some of the stuff that's
happened before
but obviously the other big news is that
wonder woman 1984
is now coming out in december right on
christmas
so they just decided to delay the movie
because theaters aren't totally open in
the united states yet
but the good news is it's still coming
out in 2020 at least for now
if there are any big changes to the
release schedule or anything like that
of course i'll include that in the
videos that i make for the movie
so while you wait for everything click
here for that brand new justice league
snyder cut trailer and click here for
the brand new batman trailer
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!